[Music]
my proposal to the national library of
medicine was to
develop and design artificial
intelligence
specifically a computer vision model
which could
look at a picture of pills inside a
medication bottle and accurately
identify the contents of that bottle we
are testing how that model can be used
in collaboration with the human so that
errors don't happen in the pharmacy how
do you teach a machine
if you want to a machine to
differentiate between an anomaly in
medical dispensing or not what you do is
you give the machine images of anomalies
you give the machine images of good
medications and you tell them this is
good this is bad when the algorithm can
make this link then if you give the
algorithm a new image
the algorithm can predict this image
belongs to which class is it the good
group or the bad girl so fundamentally
it's a matching decision
done in a fancy mathematical way so the
way we see this being implemented is
once we have that picture of pills in
the bottle we can use this model to
predict what medication it is in that
image and cross-reference it with the
expected or intended medication that was
supposed to be filled
in this way we can support pharmacists
in their double check verification of
the patient getting the right pill in
the right bottle the results were
surprisingly positive
and we found that
our algorithm can predict with an
accuracy above 99.5
but what one thing that we are afraid of
even though 0.5 percent of errors can be
critical our hope is that
in those cases where the algorithm is
wrong the algorithm can tell us that it
is not confident in its results then at
least the human can double check
our next step is to conduct the
experiment with pharmacists and through
that we are going to track how their
trust change
over time on a trial to trial basis so
through the experiment we can collect
participants responses their
physiological signals
and
we want to use eye tracking and by
analyzing their responses and signals we
can track how their trust changes over
time how their behaviors their
performance changes over time the
ultimate goal of this project is to
develop safer systems that can be used
to save lives and prevent medication
errors from causing harm to patients it
means tons to me as an engineer i
believe our ultimate mission is to
propose solutions that can be used to
enhance people's life being part of the
projects doing just that the national
library of medicine's financial support
of this project has really been
invaluable so really they've been
instrumental in making all of this
research possible without it we would
not have had the capability to collect
all this data to do all this analysis
and generate the promising results we
have right now
[Music]